[Music]
you might think this is austria or
switzerland but what if i told you this
is italy but listen carefully if i told
you that you'd expect the people there
to be speaking italian right
well then it'd be wrong the main spoken
language here is German Sophie from
Coeur d'Alene isn't thinking and of
course this is South Tyrol in fact we
think that Italian is the main language
spoken in Italy but no Italy is full of
dialects and languages that are hardly
understandable from one another someone
from Veneto in the north could hardly
understand somebody from Sicily in the
south yes Italy is a country of
contrasts and the same goes for their
politics
can you imagine a far-right party
forming a coalition with a liberal
populist one could you imagine a
trump-like Republican a lying with
someone who advocates for a basic income
for the poor well this is pretty much
what has happens in Italy so how is it
possible for the right and the left join
forces to form a government that can run
the country well in this video we're
gonna tell you that story
[Applause]
[Music]
Italy is a country of contradictions on
the one hand it's the country
surrounding the Vatican and it maintains
respect for its Catholic traditions but
on the other hand they had silvio
berlusconi a man famous for his orgies
as the prime minister for many years
[Music]
on one hands they are one of the most
over regulated countries in Europe with
red tape all over the place on the other
hand the black market here is bigger
than almost anywhere else in Europe if
that doesn't sound like enough
contradictions to you then check this
out
Italy's government is now a coalition of
a far right-wing party and a far
left-wing one now it's true the five
star movement isn't exactly a far left
political party at least not in the
Ocasio cortes kind of way but what do
you call a party that advocates for
things like basic income for the poor or
reducing for salaries of politicians so
they're more like the working-class
[Music]
and the same goes for the far right wing
many of you might say that the Liga
Party is not as extreme as other ultra
politicians but what do you call an
anti-immigration ultra nationalist party
then the funniest thing about this party
is that they began as a secessionist
movement in facts originally Liga was
called lega Nord which means the
Northern League and they wanted Italy to
be split into two different countries
now however they've changed their minds
and present as the Paragons of Italian
pride but hold on a second because you
might now be wondering why don't even
care about this well first of all that's
because of Italy's size Italy has the
third biggest economy in the eurozone
and suffers from the worst recession if
they fall Europe might fall too and if
you're a Falls the rest of the world may
fall along with it but also the case of
a coalition of opposite extremes can
serve as a cautionary tale for many
other countries something similar
happens in Greece for instance when the
leftists ERISA forms a coalition with
the right-wing annal or even the Czech
Republic where the Communist Party
shares an office with a xenophobic group
and a liberal one so definitely yes
Italy helps us understand how the
political spectrum is changing elsewhere
so now the question is how is even
possible that the right and the left
could merge together can this strange
formula succeed in order to bring the
country out of its collapse well today
we're going to answer all of these
questions but before we do let's take a
look back at the history
[Music]
from lega Nord to just lega as we said
before there are a lot of different
languages in Italy approximately 34
distinct dialects in fact but the
difference is they don't stop there you
can also tell which region is which when
it comes to economics southern Italy has
an unemployment rate close to 20 percent
in places like Sicily water shortages
were a common thing until very recently
and most of the people who work in
agriculture but northern Italy is a
totally different country this is where
brands like Ferrari and Lamborghini were
born cities like Milan de famous
worldwide for their fashion industry
their factories and their high standard
of living their unemployment rate is a
third of that in the south and their
income will be double that of the
southerners the big divide is what
explains the birth of the Northern
League party in the 90s as I said at the
beginning of this video the party was
founded as a regionalist secessionist
movement the forerunner was umberto
bossy originally he wanted his own
region body where Milan is to become
independent from the rest of Italy but
then one day he thought well why not
unify several northern regionalist
movements into one
[Music]
this is how the biggest separatist
movement in Italy was born originally it
was not meant to be a right or a left
wing party in fact its founders came
from pretty much everywhere on the
political spectrum they had one goal and
one goal only to split Italy into
basically the country they wanted to
create was called padania and it
comprised of all the northern italian
regions as with the separatist movements
they claimed several cultural
differences but unlike with Scottish
separatism the main reason for this
self-determination movements was money
basically
Bosse claims that Rome was stealing
money from the rich regions to give to
the poor
so therefore they'd be better off going
off on their own and believe me when it
comes to hating Italy it was pretty
straightforward
when I see the Italian flag I feel like
I used the green white and red to clean
my act
umberto bossy bossy went as far as
declaring padania independent from Italy
in 1996 he owned a independent sovereign
tada lapa Dania but look that separatist
as they might be this northern league
was still an Italian party this means
they had to play by the Italian rules
and run for the Italian parliament and
in order to expand their national
influence they became one of the most
loyal allies of Berlusconi this helps
them get very good results because their
voters could see that despite being a
regional party the Northern League had
enough power to influence politics and
bring lots of perks to the regions that
they represent it wakeup padania with
the Northern League against the thieves
of Rome but as influential as they could
be they could only get up to eight point
three percent of the vote this meant
that they were still a small political
party but things changed in 2012 that
was the year when Umberto basi suffered
a stroke and had to leave the party his
successor was the man here Matteo
salvini he had a radical change in mind
for the party first of all he changed
the name so it went from northern league
to just league and that kind of
rebranding it means one thing and that's
the party was evolving the electoral
program it was not focused on the
separation of the north from the south
anymore finally the enemy it wasn't Rome
but rather who was the immigrants
[Music]
more immigrants mean more criminals
salvini is working on a repatriation
plan and so what happens to that anti
Italian feeling I'm bei still the
biggest enemy of the Petain Ian's well
if you think a party you can't change
its mind from one day to the other well
think again
raise your head Italy I'm proud of being
Italian we are the best country in the
world we just need to have a little bit
of work and a little less taxes Matteo
salvini
and boom there you go now the former
Northern League could apply to all
Italian voters both southern and
northern this means a bigger voting
market and better results and I know you
might be thinking right now can anybody
take a party that can change its core
ideology virtually overnight seriously
and the answer was oh yes make our
victory at Italian elections the times
they are a-changin but if this doesn't
seem crazy enough to you let's take a
look at the other player in this game
the Italian populist laughed
the big joke it's the year 2009 and
Italy is dealing with a big crisis the
European Union wants budget cuts and
Berlusconi in his government they're in
dire straits
that's the fertile grounds on which the
five stars movement was founded during
those years a famous comedian beppe egg
Rio started a platform
he had a little to no idea how big his
blog and his movement were about to
become perhaps the most interesting
moment of the movements developing phase
was the 2007 vaffanculo day in bologna
literally this means [ __ ] off day it was
a huge advancement to collect signatures
to change the venn electoral law they
wanted to ban people convicted of crimes
from running for parliamentary election
but the real opportunity for Pepe Grillo
came some years later the Italian
economy was still struggling more and
more citizens couldn't make ends meet
and this is when Italy got a fully
technocratic president Mario Monti a
technocrat is somebody who claims not to
have any specific ideology just tries to
solve problems and manage politics based
on expertise and analysis but many
Italians this seemed to be an imposition
from the European Union who wanted more
and more budget cuts and more austerity
so this anger is what gave a mint in
Tibet they agree Leo and his five star
movement the movement started winning
and placing its members in regional and
local cabinets this momentum gave him a
chance to run in the 2013 general
election where they were the second most
popular party after the Democratic Party
surpassing everyone's expectations they
gained more than 8 million votes which
is a pretty huge number for a brand new
party
the elections results are in huge
victory for the five star movement the
websi forea for the first party in the
Chamber of Deputies the movement started
an anti-establishment force and
therefore at the beginning it didn't
seem to have a very detail-oriented
plan but all the work it paid off and
all those votes gave them the push they
needed it was time for a detailed plan
it was time to become more structured
their first huge win meant even more
wins and the movement swings the
movements ideology became Clara directed
democracy as an evolution of
representative democracy the idea that
citizens would no longer delegate their
power to parties was at the base of
Russo and online voting platform through
Russo the registered users of m5s
discuss approve or reject legislative
proposals for example the choice to
support the abolition of Al or against
immigrants was taken online by the
movements members even if the final
decision was against Korea's own opinion
below the m5s registered voters say no
to making legal immigration a criminal
offense another chapter of the party's
life began when Luigi de Meyer came into
power in 2017 in 2018 he became the
Deputy Prime Minister of Italy and
Minister of Economic Development labour
and social policies the improbable
ascent of a 31 year old college dropout
and former soccer stadium Russia is
really a measure of the country's
turbulent political landscape and so on
one hand we have a seasoned to
right-wing politician all on the other
hands we have a 31 year old freshman and
they were tied together in an unlikely
marriage by that 2018 election open
marriage
Italy is infamous for having weaker than
usual political alliances and parties
since the country was proclaimed a
republic in 1946 it has had 29 prime
ministers with an average government
length of just 2.5 years every election
is a brand new start for everyone the
last big change came in 2018 when a new
government was established after a very
complicated post-election period the new
government's is an alliance as we said
between the anti-establishment 5-stars
movements and the far-right league the
populist wave split Italy in half the
South voted for the five star movement
and the north voted for the lega
[Music]
but both sides expressed a vote of
protest against the more traditional
parties like the Democratic Party these
new numbers show real shift in Italy's
electoral geography the success of the
two most anti-establishment forces is
mostly due to economic uncertainty the
outsiders have become the mainstream
immediately after the elections the
five-star movements the party that got
the most votes needed to find a
coalition party the choice was the
leaguer
[Music]
Italy election populist five-star and
League to vie for power but this
marriage wasn't an easy one it took ten
weeks to reach an agreement the two
parties they were adversaries before the
election but at the same time they
became the largest groups able to muster
a majority in both houses and so the
five star brought to the table 32% and
the league brought 17 and with that thus
began the new government we're now a few
months in the to deputy Prime Minister's
are doing as much as possible to fulfill
the promises they made to their voters
salvini is trying to crack down on
immigration and to pass a flat rate tax
of 15 percent for companies and
individuals which experts would say
would cut tax revenues by 80 billion
euros per year DeMaio is trying to make
a huge basic income reform happen it's
universal income for the poor that would
cost an estimated 17 billion euros per
year the two leaders they're basically
in an open marriage they're together but
they're still looking around for
partners both parties are still trying
to get the biggest amounts of political
capital possible for the next election
cycle but pleasing and electorates is in
itself a very difficult feat to
accomplish even without further
obstacles
but Dolce vida slips away again as Italy
tumbles back into recession the country
is now in a recession just as the
Italian deputy Prime Minister's stated
that Italy was on the cusp of an
economic miracle in 2018 that gdp
decreased by 0.2 percent this is the
third recession in 10 years but the
Italian PM says not to worry
he stated that a recession is determined
by the European economic cycle or
whatever that means while politicians
playing the blame it on the people who
were there before card many Italians are
extremely worried about how this
recession could have an impact on their
lives for years to come Italy is the
second largest debt in the euro area
after Greece but its economy is eight
times larger and a crisis this big could
severely [ __ ] the eurozone so now the
question is is it possible that we'll
see a similar alliance in other
countries maybe this alliance can save
the country from further crisis or maybe
it's going to make things worse well
please leave your answer in the comments
section below and of course do not
forget to visit our friends at
reconsider Mediacom the podcast that
provided the voices in this video that
are not mine if you like this video
please give it a thumbs up and as always
I'll see you next time and if you want
to learn more about politics and here
even more of my lovely voice you can
join us at reconsider media we have a
podcast at reconsider mediacom slash
podcast see you there
[Music]